the movie begins in a strict shaolin
monastery it consists of several young
men competing to be the best kung fu
master of all time the most naive and
untalented one of them all is a young
man named little mute who doesn't speak
for an unknown reason he struggles to
keep up with his fellow students making
him the laughingstock one afternoon the
master orders all his pupils to do a
special task that will help them learn
the famous weightless technique he asks
them to fetch two whole buckets of water
from a river while wearing heavy iron
shoes that weigh more than 5 kilograms
on each leg not just that but after
filling the buckets they have to walk a
mile uphill once they master this
technique they will be like birds able
to jump on roofs and perform aerial
acrobatics little mute's classmates see
that he is excited about the task and
allow him to go first they are so
confident in his incompetence that they
know he will be the last one to complete
the task as they had predicted he fills
the bucket early but can barely walk
with the shoes weighing him down
everyone surpasses him leaving him the
last one climbing the hill eventually he
even drops the bucket and sits down
hopelessly he has been trying his very
best to survive in the monastery but a
failure like this shakes his spirit as
he thinks about how he got to this point
in life we are taken to a flashback a
few years ago little mute's father was
killed by a masked robber for money the
killer was a kung fu master who beat
them up badly before killing the man
hence the only reason little mute joined
the monastery is to become skilled
enough to kill the murderer one day
lost in his thought he only comes back
to reality when a nun approaches him on
seeing that he has given up on the task
she encourages him with motivating words
the nun's name is five plums and she is
also a kung fu expert after talking to
her for a while little mute completes
the task with great effort however since
he is the last one the master calls him
lazy he even reveals that no student in
several years has taken as long as him
to complete the task little mute is made
to chop wood for the entire month as
punishment while he is doing so outside
the monastery he is approached by a
drunk monk initially the man blabbers
something about perseverance in kung fu
which little mute has no interest in but
then he reveals a secret about the
monastery the two end up in a hidden
chamber behind the waterfall where only
the high-level masters are allowed to
come there an old man has been held
prisoner with his hands and legs chained
to the wall to little mute who doesn't
know what the man's crime was the
punishment seems irrational and harsh
two monks arrive in the cave and give
the prisoner food and water when they
leave little mute comes into view and
helps the prisoner eat the gesture wins
the prisoner's trust and he finds out
little mute is not one of the monks
minions he devours the food and asks the
kid to bring him wine the next time i've
got 50 bucks that says that prisoner
killed little mute's dad in the
following scene the best student of the
monastery gets ready for the final task
that every student must complete before
graduating from the shaolin monastery
the task's name is the wooden test where
a person must enter a narrow hallway
containing 36 shaolin wooden men they
are mechanical dummies that attack
anyone who enters the hallway with great
speed and strength each one of the
mechanical dummies is 50 times faster
and stronger than an average human so
the task is extremely difficult the
student enters with confidence but is
beaten so badly that he has to be
carried outside the master reprimands
him for being overconfident and lectures
everyone else to take it as a lesson to
never underestimate the final test the
following day during lunch little mute
saves a bun under his clothes for the
prisoner he also steals a little bit of
wine from the drunken monk then when no
one is looking he returns to the cave
behind the waterfall and meets the
prisoner again the man happily drinks
the wine and promises to reward him when
he escapes the prison the two chat for a
long time about the wooden test
according to the prisoner the test is a
joke he claims that he would have torn
the wooden men apart in no time if it
were him little mute listens to him
attentively but doesn't necessarily
believe him the prisoner also reveals
that the reason for his imprisonment was
he was practicing a new kung fu
technique called lion's roar the monks
didn't like that he was getting more
powerful than their entire lot so they
apprehended him the next day little mute
is assigned to kitchen duty and tries to
seal wine for the second time however
the monk catches him this time and
teaches him a lesson he is ordered to
clean the kitchen every day until the
end of the month as punishment after
sweeping the kitchen spotlessly clean
for hours he impresses the drunken monk
and is let off the hook this time later
he again goes to the prisoner with food
impressed by his kindness the man
decides to teach him kung fu techniques
even though he is chained his techniques
are primarily different from that of the
monks but little mute continues to learn
them with diligence there are some
principles that the prisoner stands by
but little mute doesn't agree with like
ignoring the rule of shaolin altogether
and always ending the battle with a kill
other than following such rules little
mute becomes the prisoner's best people
and works hard for the next few months
one afternoon he is practicing outside
the cave when five plums seize him she
notices that the kung fu style he is
practicing is not the usual one taught
in the monastery it is dangerous and
mostly used by criminals who divert from
the path of what actual kung fu teaches
she advises little mute that a man
should never learn kung fu to spread
violence and evil it is a sacred art
that one must use only to defend
themselves and others the kung fu he is
learning defeats its purpose hence he
will have to unlearn the art five plums
then starts training him in the gliding
snake style the principle of this style
of kung fu is the exact opposite of the
style that the prisoner is teaching him
little mute continues learning from both
masters and has the option to choose
between their principles as time passes
he masters both techniques and becomes a
fighter like no other one day after
training the prisoner tells him that he
has learned everything there is to the
lion's roar style and is now ready to
face the wooded men test knowing that
this will be the last time they meet
before little mute graduates the
prisoner gives him a tiny piece of paper
that he wants to be taken to the cashier
of the evergreen medicine shop since it
is the least little mute can do for his
master he agrees then comes the day when
little mute is supposed to take the
final test everyone thinks it is a joke
until he goes into the wooden alley and
actually fights well using the skills
taught by both his teachers he manages
to defeat the wooden dummies in the end
and graduates with flying colors before
leaving the monastery he goes to meet
the head monk for the past few years not
even a single person has passed the
wooden test which makes the monk believe
that little mute is doing something
different little mute doesn't say
anything but the master eventually
figures out that he met the prisoner he
prays to god for forgiveness on little
mute's behalf and asks if the prisoner
gave him anything the man stays loyal to
his master and doesn't reply before he
leaves he is handed a wooden scroll and
is asked to meet the sublime master in
the hills in the following scene we see
little mute meeting the cashier of the
medicine shop upon reading the message
he instantly recognizes who it is from
it is then revealed that the prisoner is
none other than kang the leader of the
bandit named the green dragon he wasn't
imprisoned because he was a threat to
the monks but because he used his skill
to spread violence and kill innocent
people in the message he has asked the
people of his gang to await his return
still unaware of this little mute
continues living life as usual he ends
up in a restaurant where the members of
the same gang are misbehaving with the
owner's daughter orchid little mute
saves her from the thugs and gains
appreciation from her father as a result
he is allowed to stay in there in for as
long as he wants one night the monks of
the shaolin monastery hear a loud roar
when they rush to check the cave they
find it empty kang has mastered the
lion's roar technique and escaped the
same night the members of the dragon
gang trouble orchid again they want to
abduct her and present her to their
master as his mistress when he arrives
she tries to fight them but is
ultimately kidnapped the following day
little mute and a waiter from orchid's
restaurant go out looking for her on
their way they come across kang fighting
the monks from the monastery who are
trying to stop him from running away
unaware of kang's true identity little
mute helps him escape by distracting the
monks the gang leader is thankful and
agrees to help them find the missing
girl in return after that the three go
to a restaurant to eat since kang hasn't
had good food in a long time suddenly
kang notices a bald man outside the
house and kills him assuming that he is
a monk when the shop owner retaliates he
refuses to accept his mistake and
instead blames the dead man for being
bald
god damn baldies he even kills the
entire family of the restaurant owner in
a fit of rage little mute is shocked as
he never thought the person he respects
so much would kill an entire innocent
family when he tries to reason with the
man he and the waiter are kicked out of
the house surprisingly enough when the
two return to the inn later orchid also
returns home unharmed she says that the
thugs let her go without saying why the
next day little mute randomly remembers
the scroll that he was supposed to give
to the sublime master without wasting
more time he goes to the hill and meets
the blind master unfeeling the scroll he
finds out that little mute is kang
student initially he berates little mute
for choosing the wrong path but promises
to show him the right way he then
reveals that he was kang's master in the
monastery and the one who taught the
gangster everything about kung fu
however kang repaid his master with
violence and began killing people
misusing his lessons in the end he was
captured and imprisoned but the sublime
master blamed himself for kang's deeds
and blinded himself
that is some dobby the house elf [ __ ] he
now lives in the hills as a hermit but
is ready to help the monastery if his
former pupil is threatening its safety
the current head monk is afraid that the
monks have grown old if kang and his
gang land an attack on the monastery
they won't be able to defend themselves
the only person who can help them is
little mute hence the sublime master
hands him a book containing the ultimate
kung fu style it is the most dangerous
and sacred technique of all which only a
few monks are able to master over the
next few years kang and his people plan
an attack while little mute trains in
his third kung fu style he is made to
carry 300 kilograms of rocks on his
shoulders for hours alongside other
brutal exercises under the guidance of
the head monk he manages to master the
style in a few years now with three
different kung fu techniques at his
disposal little mute is ready to fight
any battle then one day kang and his
people finally attack the monastery when
little mute tries to stop them kang
laughs revealing that he was the one who
killed his father long ago
at least 300 000 of you owe me 50 bucks
now i'm rich a shocked little mute
speaks for the first time in years he
reveals that he had vowed to never let a
word out of his mouth until he finds his
father's killer the revelation is
followed by a final showdown between
kang and little mute kang uses lion's
roar technique and defends against all
of little mute's snake style attacks
initially the clashing technique works
in kang's favor but when he tries to
attack he faces the same problem finally
little mute uses the ultimate style and
turns the fight around even after being
beaten brutally and refusing to land any
fatal attacks he manages to win in the
end to everyone's surprise kang accepts
defeat and is happy that his only
student has mastered the teachings
however it turns out to be a ruse to
take little mute by surprise kang plans
to use the deadly slicing throat move on
him but little mute moves just in time
and the attack lands on kang himself he
dies because of the impact and his gang
runs away in fear in the last scene
little mute returns to the monastery and
turns into a monk
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching